Neil Selinger 1975 Columbia College and
accepted this morning by his wife Rima
grad I love accepting the award for my
husband at Columbia I have been hearing
about Columbia since the day I met him
we entered his freshman right after the
riots there were extraordinary
temptations to do things other than
study Neil I think a little bit like me
imbibed slightly but remembered that our
primary reason was to be at college and
to learn and to gain experience there
was a residual pride that he kind of
carried with him I knew that I wanted to
go here from the time I was eight years
old Neil was a very mature competent
comfortable guy in a world that was
frenzied and complicated and hectic my
sister emily is 21 and she's about to go
into her senior year
the film major at Columbia College the
University and my sister Julia will be a
freshman at Columbia in the fall they
always wanted them to be open to any
other choices but I knew that deep down
that was his dream that they would come
here when I was a freshman here my
father took an alumni course in
literature humanities he was going
through this process of reading all
these books that he had forgotten about
or he had forgotten the details about
and I was reading them for the first
time Neil told me that when he went to
his 15th college reunion that it was
very sparsely attended by his classmates
that was my first reunion there were ten
people in total including spouses and
when you talked to some of the
classmates who weren't there they shared
with him that they agreed with him about
the fantastic education that they had
but they felt that the student services
were not what they could have been like
a true Colombian Neil focused on the
real important issue of the Alumni
Association and that is students it was
very proud of the fact that he
instituted some changes he loved working
as part of the Alumni committee he liked
being with his Columbia colleagues
Richard Witten was one of the people
that convinced meal that retirement was
a great thing it'll free you up for more
time to spend on alumni activities which
in fact it did he did leave his law firm
he could pursue many other interests
including you know writing this
fantastic book that's right from the
heart until he was diagnosed and then
wasn't able to participate anymore
there's little doubt in my mind that had
Neal been able to he would have risen to
the highest ranks of the Alumni
Association because of his dedication to
the school in some ways the disease gave
him freedom because he could actually
focus on the things that he really cared
about he cared about the Alumni
Association he cared about writing he
cared about charity he cared about his
children our motto has been from the
get-go you know as much as we can one
day at a time it always really helps to
have things to look forward to
milestones special occasions and this
this this award and this whole
experience was just a huge boost for him
at a time when he really needed a boost